[Musik]
[Applaus]
allgemeine Verkehrskontrolle runter
das ist ein Cabrio ah Frilling
Schlaumeier die selber ja warum soll ich
denn dann die Scheibe runterkurbeln wir
können uns doch auch so unterhalten
außerdem müsste sie sie ja erst einmal
hochkurbeln um sie dann wieder runter zu
kurbeln und das war schon aber echt
wahrscheinlich von euren Eltern
ausgeliehen hat dass sie deswegen frech
werden Kind Kurbeln sofort
oder Wiesn oder
genau würde man den Kopf so dann haben
wir die Papiere
hier der Fahrzeugschein und mein
Führerschein
Waffenschein
was soll das denn jetzt
waffenscheinwerfer
[Gelächter]
okay gut dann ja Schatzi Paket macht es
um sie zu also ganz ganz und es verdicke
und dann
wünsche ich weiterhin gute Fahrt
über seine witzige aber helft mir nichts
die Zeiten sind vorbei oder
Campy passati wird der Franzosen treffen
so
[Applaus]